hey you ready you got five minutes
don't say come in Jesus mom I just saved
us 300 bucks that I don't want to come
it's my weekend we're all building a
family okay all of us fine
wash me that morning Matty thought of
kids out sick today
thought you were another victim no I got
my flu shot all right
what is London trying to teach us here
London's trying to teach us how not to
die now what is man versus nature man
may offer warmth he may offer food we
nature always wins
your son is lucky witnesses said he ran
into traffic it was high he was ranting
what happened everyone was dead that was
blood you think that's what you saw was
a nightmare hallucinations say
foreigners save her from what
they don't know if it's a virus or our
microbe they don't know but it's
spreading
check this out someone leaked the
footage with us how they unload on him
it's not real I mean can't be real
was happening where are you I gotta go I
gotta go
usually sure we're closed
we need place to write it up can you
yeah what was that sound
what do you see out there it's like it's
not real
where are you we're stuck
yeah you're far away from us outside all
of us these can work
when civilization ends it ends fast
Master birdie marry that's